[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to this debate on science to the
rescue
i am your host anil anantha swami we
have a wonderful panel today for this
debate
but before i introduce them let me tell
you a little bit about the debate itself
in response to the pandemic governments
are keen to say that we should listen to
the science
but this supposes there is an agreed
body of scientific knowledge
in fact there are deep differences
between the scientists involved
those advising sweden clearly had a
different theory than those advising the
uk or
italy scientists outside of epidemiology
have been critical of the
epidemiologists science is a melee of
competing and often incompatible views
so how should we respond should we stop
hiding behind the
quote-unquote science and recognize we
have to decide
can we seek to weigh and judge different
scientific opinions if we are not
ourselves experts
or should governments simply choose the
scientific theories with the most
support
or is this a route to irrational and
dangerous decision making
our panel for this debate carlo rovelli
is a italian theoretical physicist
who works mainly in the field of quantum
gravity carlo currently works in the
center of the physique
theory de luminy of ex marseille
university
and has written many popular science
books that have sold in their millions
across over 40 languages in 2019 he was
named one of the hundred most
influential thinkers in 2019
by foreign policy magazine heather
douglas is an associate professor of
philosophy
at michigan state university our
research focuses on the new
on the role of social and ethical values
of science
uh in science the nature of science is
responsibility in and for science
and the interface between science and
policy
in 2016 she was elected as a fellow of
the american association for the
advancement
of science patricia churchlin is the uc
president's professor of philosophy
emerita at the university of california
san diego
patricia is a philosopher noted for her
contributions to the philosophy of mind
and her work on the integration of
philosophy and science
she has pioneered the now extremely
fruitful
branch of philosophy of mind known as
neurophilosophy
so welcome carlo heather patricia
i will start off this debate uh with a
question
that each of you will have three minutes
to respond to and the question is
is science a progressing body of
knowledge
so carlom can we start with you
um thank you um anil thank you for the
invitation thank you for um this
question
um but i would like to start from what
you said introducing the debate
um to which i um would disagree
uh uh and and and and that my
uh perhaps uh starts
uh the actual debate i think that one
should not confuse
uh uh science with its limitation
its confusion its different opinions its
incomplete knowledge aspect from
politics
and from the political decisions the
decisions we have to take in the
pandemics
are not scientific decisions and
political decisions they have to be
taken
negotiating different values different
interests a different push in the
society it's a difficult question
whether
we prefer having more old people dying
or
uh people going into poverty and have
less resources it's it's it's a question
that doesn't have a straight
scientific answer obviously whatsoever
um different countries have chosen
different paths
uh perhaps listening to slightly
different scientific positions
but not because science has moved them
in one direction or the other
because there are different because
we're humans and we choose differently
in in different contexts
so it's wonderful for a scientist like
me
to see society uh asking signs so much
as it has happened in the current uh
pandemic
but it's very worried when politicians
try to hide
behind science and say oh science tell
us to do that nice never tell us to do
this or that it tells us that as we know
with our disagreement at the current
level of understanding
um the most reliable
prediction on the bay is is that if we
do that this will happen if we do that
this will happen if we stay home
uh perhaps less people will die given
our
medical system given this given given
that
um so finally to get to
actually your your question science is
not a
body of knowledge it's a
process a practice in which we try to
increase our knowledge
part of it is a large part of it
it's very there's a lot of
agreement and consensus uh part we
definitely don't know
we're in the dark we have no idea so we
tried all possible direction and then
there is the boundary in between in
which there is discussion
we try to get a consensus historically
what is wonderful
is that the scientific uh
way of trying to bring knowledge has
very often led to consensus not always
but
mostly led consensus and to reliable
knowledge so this is a strength of
science ignoring it is completely stupid
but the decisions are not scientific or
political
thank you carlo um that was a wonderful
opening and i think it sets us up for
the rest of the debate so heather would
uh would you like to take a stab at that
question
yeah so actually i have a different
question take a stab at which is the one
i was given
um is there such a thing as the science
and i think if we mean a set
of fixed and permanently certain facts
no there's no such thing as
the science science as carlos said it's
an ongoing critical discussion
and it's based on reasons and empirical
evidence
and i think and carlo agrees is the best
source for reliable knowledge about the
world
but doesn't produce truth with a capital
t
timeless permanent authoritative truth
um
we don't have access to such truth
through science so
what we have instead is a group of
people in continual debate discussion
over what to think about the world
people continually gathering new
evidence developing new ideas and
theories and
testing those theories against evidence
this produces
a set of evergreen and always
contestable knowledge claims
um i think that is what science is i
suspect the fact that science produces
such
changeable claims is frustrating to
non-scientists why can't the experts
just decide what is the case
why can't we just have the signs it'd be
so much more convenient
but the fact that there is no such thing
as the science that our knowledge is
always
open to being challenged by reasoned
argument and new evidence even consensus
um it's precisely why it is the best
source for reliable knowledge about the
world if it were not if it were mere
um it would be just mere dogma and not
nearly as trustworthy
so we may not have the science as a sort
of fixed facts but we have science as pr
as a practice and it is very much worth
our attention
now because ongoing debate is such a
aspect of science
on many scientific issues there will be
experts who disagree about what the best
understanding of evidence is
or in some cases even about what
constitutes the best evidence and we see
that with the current pandemic
this can make it hard on the
non-scientist which expert should be
believed
particularly when a decision has to be
made now
before debate among experts can fully
play out which can often take decades
so we almost never have the luxury to
wait until all the science is settled
before acting we have to use the
available evidence and expertise to make
a timely decision
to see what our options are what is its
stake what is most important to protect
and what we are willing to risk when
facing such complexity i think it is a
good idea to rely upon experts
those who have the requisite knowledge
and who are engaged in scientific
community debates because that's how
they maintain their expertise
but also experts who roughly share your
values
for such experts would make judgments as
you would
if you had their expertise the problem
arises
when one conflates such experts with
people who are merely saying what you
want to hear
telling those two groups apart i think
is crucial to relying upon science
responsibly
and doing so i think is the central
challenge of the 21st century
thank you heather um uh your words
yeah well both of those uh openings
we're very rich and and full of ideas
and
information i maybe will try to come at
the question in a
in a slightly different way i mean one
point uh
about the difference between policy
making
and science these would be the
coronavirus that's absolutely correct we
want to
make sure that that distinction is there
and robust
but the other thing i think that is
really important with regard to the
policy
making uh in in the last
few months is that there has been so
much uncertainty
within science about what the heck this
virus is
how it works why there is such
variability
in symptoms what it might take
to get a vaccine and i mean one of the
glorious things about the science
regarding the coronavirus was how
quickly we got the chino
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you